- [Voiceover] A cable
company with a reputation
for poor customer service
is losing subscribers
at a rate of approximately 3% per year.
The company had two million subscribers
at the start of 2014.
Assume that the company
continues to lose subscribers
at the same rate, and that
there are no new subscribers.
It's truly a bad situation for them.
Which of the following functions, S,
models the number of
subscribers, in millions,
remaining t years after the start of 2014?
So let's just think
about this a little bit.
So S of zero.
When t equals zero, this is zero years
after the start of 2014.
So this would be the number of subscribers
they had at the start of
2014, which is two million.
So S of zero is going to be two.
Remember, S is in terms of millions.
They tells us that, so S of zero is two.
What is S of one going to be?
When t equals one?
Well, one year has gone by,
so they're going to lose
3% of their subscribers,
and losing 3% is the same
thing as retaining 97%.
So it's going to be two times 0.97.
Now what happens at t
equals two after two years?
Well, they started with two million.
In one year, they were
able to only retain 97%.
And then another year goes by.
They're only going to retain 97%
of what they had the year before.
So another 97%.
I think you see the trend.
You're going to multiply by 97%
as t times, I guess is
another way to think about it.
If you say S of three,
you started with two million subscribers.
After one year, you retain 97% of them.
After another year, you're
gonna retain 97% of this,
and after another year, at t equals three,
you're gonna retain 97% of that.
97% of that.
So in general, S of t is going
to be what you started with
times 0.97
to the t power.
However many years have gone by,
you take your, I should say
retention rate to that power,
and of course, you then multiply that
times your initial starting subscribers,
and that's how much you're
going to be left with.
And let's see, which of
these choices have that?
That is this choice right over here.
Now another way you could have done it
is you could have tried to
rule out some choices here.
This one actually has
the subscribers growing.
If you multiply by 1.03 to the t,
1.03 times 1.03 times 1.03,
it's going to get larger than one.
You're gonna have more than
two million subscribers.
So as t increases, so you
can rule that one out.
In this one, every year
you're only retaining
70% of your subscribers.
You're losing 30%, not 3%.
So that one's even worse than
this already bad situation.
And then this one, this is a linear,
this is kind of a...
They're saying you're multiplying by t.
One way to realize
that this is gonna to break down very fast
is t equals zero.
This is gonna give us zero.
But if t equals zero, you
don't have zero subscribers.
At t equals zero, you have
two million subscribers.
The other way to think about it
is this was gonna increase as t increases,
while we didn't have a
decreasing number of subscribers.
So you could rule that one out as well.